[Applause]
this is a president that throughout has
tried to project a feeling of hope as
the corona virus rips through the world
and his country now bringing in the CEO
of a pharmaceutical company to the White
House to herald the results of a
possible treatment Bream to severe
really people that are not doing well
people that are sick people that have
this horrible plague that set in to our
country and that we're getting rid of
and we're going to be we're going to be
having some really incredible results we
have very promising studies coming out
on the vaccines we have promising
studies coming out on therapeutics in
the first widespread try out the drug it
did shorten the length of the
hospitalizations days for the virus and
it slightly decreased the mortality rate
but scientists say it's the first real
hope that a drug can work against the
virus we have to remember this is the
very first one it's a new drug being
used for this and it showed I would call
it a bright spot in the search just what
90 days after being notified of this of
a drug that looks like it's got very
promising results and the company that
makes it says it will donate its
stockpile which the Food and Drug
Administration cleared for use on Friday
we'll be working with the government to
determine how best to distribute that
within the United States we'll be
working very closely to get that to
patients working with FEMA working with
other parts of the government to make
sure that we get that to the patients in
need as quickly as possible because
there are patients out there that can
benefit from this medicine today that
are hospitalized and we don't want any
time to waste for that the White House
trying to project a sense of hope of a
near return to normal for the country
but as some states begin to reopen like
Georgia foreboding numbers in additional
1000 cases diagnosed in a single day an
experts say it will take as many as two
weeks to determine the true cost as
cities and towns begin to reopen
pedicle hain al Jazeera